the Joe Rogan experience there are
there's quite a few women's MMA fighters
now but it's still small in comparison
to men when you meet young girls that
look up to you do you recognize that you
have you have a very very critical and
it's a very small role there's an in
small in terms of a small amount of
people providing that role yeah as role
models to young kids that are thinking
about fighting when a young girl meets
you like oh my god it's the karate
hottie like is it is it weird to you
like what is that feeling like to you
when you meet a young girl and you say
oh my god this is me when I was 16
yeah it's amazing it really is to know
that just through my story that I've
touched people's lives you know I get
approached a lot by my parents you know
that are happy that I'm pursuing what
what I'm pursuing even being a mom you
know so I think that's really cool just
because I feel like when I was pregnant
how would you daughter now she's eight
yeah so when I was that she was much
younger for some reason oh yeah she's a
shrimp that's why I saw the pictures
when she was younger - she's anybody I
this might be too much information but
[Music]
after I had my daughter she's been to
every single one of my fights and I had
my first fight back when I was ten
months old and I was still breastfeeding
I like breastfed her when she was ten
months old not when you wow you had a
fight why you were breastfeed yeah that
was your first fight my first night back
okay how many fights did you have before
your daughter oh I had a good amount I'd
say I don't even been fighting for ten
years professionally it's 12 years
mm-hmm mm-hmm yeah a good amount I was
25 when I had her when I was pregnant
but yeah I just remember being pregnant
and being everybody talks about like
postpartum depression but I was really
depress during my pregnancy I mean don't
get me wrong I love to being pregnant
and there was a lot of memories that I
had with her being in my belly and me
feeling her and all of this and that
that those moments I treasure forever
but I was depressed like I couldn't do
what I wanted to do it's not like I
could go out and you know I felt was
feeling bad I couldn't just throw the
gloves on and go out and spar and hit
somebody in the face you know what you
do to relieve stress and I just I I
watched everybody get better and I
watched everybody progress and and fight
and it you know it ain't me alive and I
just I there was just so much
uncertainty and so much unknown was my
body gonna be the same you know was I
gonna even want it was I gonna have time
to do it there was just so much that I
didn't know and so I was I was really
down then and I I get a lot of moms that
approach me and they tell me that
because I went back and continued to
pursue my dream that they did - mm-hmm
and I think that that's cool that is
cool now when you say you had your first
fight back 10 months that's that's a
really for people that don't recognize
that's a very short amount of time to
rebound from giving birth and then get
yourself back in shape and then get
yourself into fighting shape where
you're like I'm ready to take a fight
and then train for the fight I mean that
is a incredible process to go through in
ten months it was crazy it really was my
body was when you when you have a baby
your your bones kind of like shift apart
from each other and you gain weight and
I after I had my daughter I found out I
well during my pregnancy I got
gestational diabetes and in my game like
50 pounds I gained a lot like I looked
like the blueberry on Willy Wonka
chocolate but um yeah how long did it
take you to bounce back were you in the
gym again I probably stayed with my
daughter for the first three months that
I had her
I just wanted to be a mom I just wanted
to be with her and I wanted to nurture
her and you know enjoy my time with her
and I think it was after three months
where I was like I I want to kick some
butt yeah I wanna relieve some stress
and coach wink and coach Jackson and all
my teammates were so supportive and so I
would come into the gym and I'd have you
know my diaper bag in one hand and my
gym bag in the other and my car seat and
I'd come into the gym and I'd set it all
down and I'd get wrapped up and she'd be
in the car seat and she chill out and
Wow she would start to cry coach wink or
at coach Jackson would pick her up and
then you know they'd let me spar and you
know she needed to get she needed to eat
I would go to the room and feed her and
then come back and and and we made it
work
Wow yeah so um so I started training for
that and I really couldn't run to lose
the weight because my joints and my
bones were like all spread apart you
know so when you say spread apart like
what what actually does happen
well they I mean I don't know like all
the the science behind it but they just
say that in order to like have the baby
like everything kind of separates from
each other your your bones like loosen
and you're like more agile and loose and
stuff like that
and so you felt it I felt a big
difference in the way your body performs
yeah for sure I felt it and so instead
of running I would swim from my cardio
and that helped me hmm
because it wasn't hard on my joints or
anything like that it kind of helps me
get back into shape and you kind of just
you kind of just go with the flow and
figure it out as you go it was really
hard I was worried that I was worried
that because I got back into sparring
and this and that that I would go dry
like my milk would go dry but I didn't
it's just my body just figured okay this
is what what you do and I still produce
milk and everything and it was really
sensitive at first to get hit and and
then I just got used to the pain and
then wow
I don't even have one of those own like
yikes yeah I would imagine your yeah I
mean if your memories you know they pump
up yeah it's it's the body is just so
amazing no like it'll it'll adapt to
what it needs to adapt to and and when I
trained it I got used to the pain and it
didn't hurt anymore and then you know my
I would only produce as much as she
needed yeah
now when you fought Tenma it's pretty
incredible for your daughter to have
only seen you fighting that's got to be
crazy too right
you can't remember when you weren't
fighting yeah my mom kicks ass yeah she
is she's a really cool upbringing I I
think like she's just she's she's
surrounded by really cool people like
she gets to meet the coolest people in
the world and they're normal to her
because that you know she sees John and
Holly and you know that's that's auntie
Holly to her right so like you know her
expectations for for what she can be in
life I think are way higher you know and
I think because she's surrounded by
people like that that she and and that's
why I like to keep around because you
know right my dad used to always tell me
that we learned through our actions our
parents actions you know you walk the
walk you don't talk to talking so I
think the best teacher can be my actions
and for her to see it through her own
eyes I can tell they're this this and
this all day but but it's a different
story when she comes to a fight with me
and I am the champion the 105 champion
and I'm defending my belt and you know I
bust my eye open to the point where you
can't see it anymore and I lose my belt
and for her to see that and for her to
see that mommy's okay and that failure
is a part of life and that I still love
what I do
and I'm gonna still go after you know my
set of dreams because failure is a part
of your journey you know that's amazing
lesson for a kid learn and to
see that at a high level growing up with
her mother on this giant stage in front
of all these people in the crowd and
television that's amazing for her yeah
and because if people ask me all the
time like is aren't you afraid that
she's gonna see you get home and this
and that but why would you want to
shield them from that stuff I know I
know it's it's hard it's a hard pill to
swallow you don't want your children to
see you her and this and that but I'd
rather her see it and be prepared for it
you know because life isn't fair life
isn't sunshine and rainbows all the time
it's challenging for her and challenging
things for kids that's how they grow
[Applause]